with an estimated 22.5 billion dollars
in revenue raked in since 2008
the marvel cinematic universe has become
an entertainment titan
some of the stories behind the creative
process that brought the franchise to
life are at this point kind of legendary
how do you separate
fact from fiction one example of what
seems like a tall tale in the mcu's
origin story is the claim by robert
downey jr that a specific fast food item
in the first iron man movie was included
because the restaurant that sells it
saved his life and we can tell you up
front that this weird assertion
is actually true after all if you can't
trust a millionaire movie star touting
the benefits of eating burger king
what can you trust the backstory here is
important
folks old enough to remember what it was
like to be scared of y2k
might also recall that there was a time
when robert downey jr
wasn't the most valuable asset in the
disney vault in the 80s he was a brat
pack kid and a one-season saturday night
live cast member
in 1992 he starred in a biopic that
really brushed over some of the more
problematic
aspects of charlie chaplin's life and
between 1996 and 2001
the future avenger was best known for
his frequent arrests for cocaine
valium and heroin possession despite
hiring the same team of lawyers that got
oj off the hook
he wound up with a three-year sentence
in 1999
after multiple high-profile run-ins with
the law that's
where burger king comes in downey has
been forthright about his struggle with
addiction in the years since his big
comeback
touting the importance of rehabilitation
and persistence
but it was a 2008 interview with empire
magazine that saw the actor explaining
exactly what inspired him to finally get
clean
the tipping point he claimed was a
really bad burger
the interview revealed that in 2003
downey was in a car loaded with quote
tons of dope when he pulled into a
drive-through for refreshments
downey told the magazine i have to thank
burger king it was such a disgusting
burger i ordered i had that in this big
soda and i thought something really bad
was going to happen
after that he claims to have tossed his
narcotic stash into the ocean
according to downey these events went on
to inspire the scene in 2008
iron man in which tony stark experiences
an epiphany
after his time as a hostage of the ten
rings i'm an american cheeseburger
and he gets one courtesy of burger king
before holding a press conference
to announce that he's turning his life
around ceasing all weapon development at
stark industries
this turning point even gets a call back
when avengers end game brings tony's
character arc full circle
what do you want cheeseburgers
[Music]
you know you dad like cheeseburgers it's
a poignant moment made all the more
potent because
it's delivered by iron man director and
famous gourmand
john favreau of course it's not exactly
a backstory that reflects
all that kindly on burger king so
there's a lesson here about the
importance of double checking the
artist's intent before shelling out
money for product
placement but then again tony sure seems
to enjoy those bk burgers and iron man
and disgusting or not it sounds like
they might have saved robert downey jr's
life
love them or hate them it sounds like
they're doing something right
check out one of our newest videos right
here plus even more looper videos about
your favorite mcu movies are coming soon
subscribe to our youtube channel and hit
the bell so you don't miss a single one